movie supports the fact that the ancient
Egyptians were skilled in the art of
building great cities out of terrible
CGI these city of the Living Thebes is a
real ancient city in Egypt but it
doesn't sit in the direct shadow of the
pyramids of giza there was however a
city in front of the pyramids
it's called Giza also narration home of
Imhotep keeper of the dead real-life
Imhotep was a cool dude
he was an innovative architect and made
some important discoveries in medicine
and revered as a God after his death but
because of this movie the American
public will only know him as the evil
magic mummy with the giant mouth
birthplace of anak suna moon a max una
moon was a real person who was born
around a thousand years after Imhotep if
the movie is just gonna make up
characters from scratch why does it have
to be historically confusing by using
real people's names this would be like a
people thousands of years from now made
a movie where Leonardo da Vinci was a
witch doctor secretly in love with
Princess Diana maybe this is why no
other man was allowed to touch her it
isn't a sex thing they just don't want
anyone messing up her body paint yeah
Tommy Patton yeah for a body paint is
smeared it must mean someone touched her
it couldn't mean she brushed up against
something or did it herself and oddly
enough she doesn't even have that line
ready Pharaoh confronts these two
without bodyguards to resurrect the
knocks on a moon Emo's death and this
priest broke into her crypt and stole
her body so Imhotep and his goons fled
the crime scene without anyone
suspecting he murdered the Pharaoh and
stole his mistress from her crypt
without anyone stopping him man security
and Thebes are pretty sure moons Bruce
Almighty an appearance back in 1290 BC
why does she look nearly alive after
having her organs removed and did they
not mummify her knocks when a moon soul
had come back from the dead but
Pharaoh's bodyguards had followed it and
stopped him before the ritual could be
completed if he moat up in his buds
didn't ceremoniously slow login with the
book they could have completed this task
before the guard showed up all of
Imhotep priests were secured in these
torture contraptions yet for some reason
he needs to be held down by four people
the key that unlocks Imhotep sarcophagus
also unlocks both books of death and
light
the Najah would never allow him to be
released for he would arise a walking
does
a plague upon mankind and unholy
flesh-eater with the strength of Ages
even if they thought there was no way
he'd get out my risk this couldn't they
just torture and kill him normally
without giving him a chance to come back
as some kind of Superman
well three thousand years for three
thousand years this narration continued
you just got promoted this is the French
Foreign Legion and yet some American guy
is second-in-command Rick is allowed to
shoot of these horsemen with no cover
and receives no return fire also a lot
of the opposing side is using guns but
Brendan Fraser Luck's out by getting all
the ones who are swords only and we've
cornered the person we've identified as
the main character of this film so Pike
God take your time shooting him
basically all that this security system
does is tell people they found the right
place y'all wanna up the Lord nah let us
below it could kill him now but let's
make the desert decide this ritual Isis
in my librarian in the scene as soon as
the ladder goes perpendicular to the
ground the book EB was just holding
magically disappears also Rachel
Stiltskin knocking over bookshelves like
their dominoes cliche this man uses sons
of pharaohs and the plagues as
expletives just to make triple Cherie
you know we're in Egypt
Jonathan enlisted the help from the
sound designer to scare his sister also
he decides to play this prank on his
sister right after he hear what must
have been a truly scary commotion coming
from the other room when all the
bookcases fell he shrugged that off
decided nobody got hurt and then dreamed
up this stupid more importantly have you
no respect for the museum's assets and
your sister's job my dish sweet baby
sister expositional name calling this is
the man that you said Jonathan steals an
ancient artifact from for all he knows a
random drunk and is able to quickly find
him in a Cairo prison to ask him about
where he found it the Cairo prison is
arranged so inmates can punch visitors
in the face and sexually harassed
visitors from behind bars I will give
you 100 pounds to save this man's life
this is almost the exact wrong time to
begin the negotiations to save Rick's
life unfortunately for the executioner
Rick strengthened his neck muscles every
day from the time he was four survived
this hanging do you really think he's
going to show off what they didn't
ensure that he was going to go with them
but just hoping he'll show up just as
it's time to leave and when we got there
all we found was sand and blood and that
weird mummy face that appeared out of
nowhere in the sand that might have been
a marker of some sort probably warning
people to stay away from it because it's
the exact place you're looking forward
all that's missing is this guy saying
this here is my
but kill some people on a steamboat hook
without my glasses I can't see the
doctor Kotik what he meant to say was my
classes are going to be important to the
plot later so I want to make sure you
and the viewing audience know this these
Americans are smart they pay me only
half now half when I get them back the
Kairos knows Wiley Americans with their
sneaky schemes of only paying someone a
deposit before they execute the services
they were hired for so this time on my
school Ave you don't have to you can
just take the money they've given you
and Ron nealy expects me to believe Rick
didn't notice anyone the scale the side
of the boat and come over the railing
even though he was standing just feet
away dude somehow knows to go straight
to Evie's room to look for the key even
though there was no way for him to know
who she even is yeah by the way why is
there even a map to this place I know
the ancient Egyptians wanted to make
sure nobody dug the mummy up and the
Magi are sworn to protect it but
wouldn't they just know where it is and
not need a map and why make a map to the
police when the entire goal is for
nobody to dig it up ever in the history
of talk these candle flames blow around
before the guy actually opens the window
to cause the candle flames to blow
around also once he opens this up he
forgets how to shoot further reason as
to why the protectors of the ancient
city did not need to make a map ever
what was this asshole doing the whole
time is he the last resort just in case
somebody tries to escape the boat
luckily he was in the exact place he
needed to be in order to do this that's
racist how are these guys able to round
up all the horses during the boat fire
and lead them all of the shore they lost
all their stuff but they didn't lose
their endless supply of money that
allows them to buy new stuff
he almost dresses in accordance to the
local customs but still keeps her head
and most of her face uncovered for
maximum middle-eastern ease sexiness how
many different angles of camels walking
through sand do we need is it 8 shots
yes it is the main responsibility of the
mahjongg is to stand near the edge of
this cliff and trot up to the edge of
the cliff if they happen to see anyone
according to Bembridge scholars
that's where we'll find a secret
compartment containing the golden book
of amun-ra or a supposedly secret place
there sure is a lot of information about
it this may be the easiest
archaeological mission in recorded
history they walk right to this ancient
undiscovered city they walk right up to
the Anubis head which was still
completely intact went into a crevasse
on the ground and walked right up to the
Mummy's tomb tombs that were originally
constructed to be seen can sometimes
take months and maybe even years to find
and these guys just walked up to one in
a matter of days if the Magi don't want
people disturbing mo tops grave they are
doing a colossal EVP job according to
these hieroglyphics
so let's poke a giant hole in the
ceiling causing potentially large and
heavy objects to fall likely killing us
Oh God
blue gold what is this a Kay Jewelers
also why wouldn't he assumed it was some
other blue stones it's blue gold doesn't
exist is it because he's an idiot and
the movie also assumes we are idiots and
cannot relate to any other stone that
holds value he shall not be named all
The Mummy flesh-eating scarab beetles
make easy Mac sounds while moving
through a person's body Evelyn please
the pronoun game so Rick and Jonathan
have to ask who the hell he is
the Magi managed to kill no one of any
importance to the story leave this place
on its side you have one day one day
you're giving them one day before and
earlier in the movie they considered
killing Rick just for knowing about this
place so why are they cool with 30
people knowing also he couldn't have
just calmly told them this in the first
place
instead he shoots the place up first to
build trust what is a place like me
doing in a girl like this you kill all
who open this chest and assimilate their
organs and fluids it's almost like the
ancient Egyptians who set all this up
wanted someone to bring Imhotep back and
bring about the end of the world they
kept the body the organs and the black
book all together like some kind of
apocalypse blue apron delivery given
that everyone knows about the acid salt
incident from before why is anyone
opening anything around here without the
slightest bit of caution do you have to
message death is only the beginning
while being viciously consumed by
flesh-eating scarab beetles he took the
time to leave a note
who cares about a book where the hell is
the treasure right because no one would
care pay a lot of money for an ancient
book that predates all other books that
supposedly brings people back to life
dr. Allen is supposed to be one of the
smart ones right is he still trying to
open the oldest book in recorded history
with brute force Gharib skeletons flesh
eaters these beetles were supposed to
eat him alive they did a job he's still
juicy for God's sake mess I bet buyer in
Mattapan soupy case its way to a yacht
with a yard
only to happen if they hadn't opened the
sarcophagus would the mummy still be
able to Collazo a out man kind of
unlucky two different teams open the
exact two containers required to unleash
a plague on the earth also it takes a
full hour for this mummy to movie I know
what I said this wall of grasshoppers
know exactly who the unimportant
characters in this movie are and go to
town on them I guess with all the
hullabaloo dr. Allen stole the book back
from Evy to create this picturesque
moment what is this crazy Holi with
scooby-doo doors that allows the mummy
to always be behind this guy this secret
door leads Eevee to mr. Burnes who just
lost his eyes this must be a relatively
small underground - hmm but you can
still enunciate sounds that require the
use of a tongue
I thought these beetles ate people very
slowly so why is this dude immediately
devoured you have unleashed a creature
that we have feared for more than 3000
years
well you don't know why we didn't
destroy that map and kill you when we
had the chance but we are an insanely
stupid group of people sworn to protect
something so dangerous what does he do
to her we save him save them before the
creature could finish his work excuse me
what when were you down in that area to
save him from anything a couple of
minutes ago he was down here with Evelyn
and the mummy lost interest in him when
he saw Rachel Vice as one does then
blast from the past earshot the mummy
and immediately went into the next room
where you assholes are now so when did
you get the chance to save the dude with
the glasses
Imhotep takes so much time to kill Benny
that he's able rolodex through all the
main religions in their languages and
ends on the one that convinces the mummy
not to kill it also Benny wears a
janitor keys style necklace containing
the symbols of all the major world
religions just in case his life is
threatened by an otherworldly being who
may be persuaded by one of those
religions
Imhotep literally pulls gold out of his
ass instead of just finding an exit like
everyone else Imhotep finds a low
ceiling in this cave to punch his hand
through Prince emo tips thanks you for
your hospitality doesn't immediately
kill Barrens this is the supernatural
equivalent of playing with your food
mummy with untold power decides to reach
deep down into his bag of magic tricks
and push Rick really hard ex machina now
because of you have you dude you failed
because you failed the woman who
arranged this mission was right under
Terrance's goddamn nose and he let her
lead with the map a key to Imhotep stoom
and the Book of the Dead and our deaths
idea of guarding the city is just
looking at it while random armies come
and go bedroom door can be nearly locks
from the outside seeing as how Imhotep
needs to kill Daniels and Henderson in
order to
rejuvenating this is kind of like
protecting your cookie jar from cookie
monster by enlisting two of your most
delicious cookies to stand watch could
have at least found a cap to hang out
with them money could have killed him
right here but let rather do the horror
movie cliche Bowl
Imhotep isn't going to be sneaking up on
anyone making supernatural swoopy sounds
like that the director said let's have
your character human like an apple all
the way down to his core and in
silhouette it'll make you look like even
more of a silhouette II asshole look at
I got this cat that showed up in the
story only just now really turned out
useful also for some reason they don't
keep this cat with them from this point
forward also it occurs to me that these
people should be rounding up all the
cats they can find and putting them in
strategic places which reminds me they
could have set up a whole cat colony
around the mummies - and let a bunch of
strays guard this lost city into
eternity the majolica - provided them
food and kitty litter and the world
would be safe this works it is time to
make you mine
whatever all eternity even though EB
makes it clear that she can understand
what Imhotep is saying Benny still
translates for him I'll be seeing you
and
don't you want to kill this guy for
throwing a cat in your face like
seriously all he has to do is kill Rick
right now and the movie is essentially
over dr. Terrence wastes his martyrdom
on these slow stupid zombies instead of
just escaping with everyone else got a
question if you can transform him into a
sandstorm and travel that way
why bother walking ever also traveling
by sand twister is just as fast as
traveling by biplane shooting at sand
this plane crash only killed the pilot
and the two men who were strapped to the
wings survived without a scratch and
worst
Winston is the character equivalent of a
unit Oscar he literally only existed to
get them back to Hamunaptra and
immediately upon that happening he dies
and not only does he die he also gets
pulled into the earth by quicksand
almost as if he and the plane never
existed also quicksand in the desert in
this very spot unable to submerge an
entire plane with the flick of a knife
rick is able to burrow a determined
beetle out of Jonathan's skin with
little or no effort also Jonathan
doesn't suffer from internal bleeding or
hemorrhaging caused by this beetle
burrowing through his arm and into his
shoulder skin is not like a tight
fitting shirt shrunk over your muscles
there's blood vessels and hotter young
shadows this asshole woke up to be
henchman just to kill people he could
easily kill himself time is not of the
essence here it's not like Imhotep is
racing the clock sure these guys should
totally be able to do the job but why go
through any of the trouble shooting this
mirror gets it to just the right angle
to initiate the light mirror trick we
saw the first time we were here did the
ancient Egyptians actually bury people
under their hidden treasure or are these
dudes just popping up right here so our
heroes will have a reason to start
running again who decided where all
these statue should go Anubis was on the
surface level while Horus is stuck down
here in the basement guess he was just
waiting down here until the plot
required him to exist kind of like
Winston the pilot Rick falls into the
trap of believing human skin can light a
match and he's right okay so there's a
book that can send Imhotep back to his
undead state and that's totally fine
but why would this book be hidden if the
worst thing you fear is the mummy
escaping is to shouldn't this book be
with the Magi at all times or destroyed
first off I was Jonathan allowed to run
crazily into this room without Rick
second off it's pretty convenient for
the book they needed was right next door
to the place they needed to go next to
stop the sacrifice he moved up is
currently on some stairs watching this
could easily be over right now but sure
let's see if your henchman can do the
job where these guys mummified in a
standing ready for battle position like
terracotta warriors without the hard
outer shell I have trouble imagining why
that's necessary or if it's even
possible finish the inscription on the
Kaaba idiots then you can control them
and until then they work for a motet
it's a seniority thing movie inspires
75% of the Pirates of the Caribbean
series these mummies adhere to the
henchman will fight one at a time rules
so rigorously most of them are actually
just standing and waiting their turn
this is the second time the Mummy's
girlfriend has experienced death by
shadow I figure whatever attack him
looked up is about to perform here he
could have done it to everyone in this
room and ended this about 45 minutes ago
he's an asshole not because he wants to
rule the world and revive his dead
girlfriend using Evelyn but because he
wasted our time
Imhotep of all people should know that
he's mortal now so why does he approach
Rick in the crew like he's still
immortal he saw his soul get dragged
away by Santa a minute ago
so why is he being dumb about this he
has another security system for this
tomb and again I'm left wondering why it
wasn't used in the first place way back
when they buried him otep in this city
underground the ancient Egyptians really
fucked up this keep Imhotep buried for
everything
that stupid gold book was the whole
reason any of this movie got started and
will be decides to just throw it away at
the last second because cue and seagulls
this lowering ceiling doesn't know where
it wants to be between these shots as if
the movie wasn't readers a lost dark
enough for you this movie gives us one
final stab at it before the credits
everywhere many turns and other doors
just closing at the last second instead
of already being closed which is what
they would be due to the synchronicity
these three rode out here on an airplane
and a sand tornado and no one else was
in the city as far as we know so we're
the that all these camels come from yes
and the respect and gratitude of me and
my people
our dad forgot it was all their fault
that Imhotep was revived in the first
place
Jimmy frogs flies locusts anything but
you in the frozen land of NATO they were
forced to eat Robins minstrels
it's not fair to all there was time now
there was was all the time I needed pay
that me and his money
[Music]
oh what a night
what a lovely day